i've talked before about the mind virus
that is trumpism and i've talked about
the
very real impact that watching fox news
and listening to trump
has on people an economist yougov poll
finds that
86 percent of trump voters
believe joe biden has not legitimately
won the election
86 percent of trump voters fell for the
trump voter fraud scam
which according to reports we got
yesterday
trump doesn't even really believe and is
using just to pay off campaign debt
trump built this up for months saying it
will be rigged
voter fraud is for a voter vote by mail
is fraudulent
etc and it worked in a washington post
poll more than 75 percent of trump
voters believe trump
should not concede so trump does
have the support of his base to continue
not conceding
which is a reminder is merely a
formality concession is not legally
relevant
now even more interesting is that when
asked whether trump should contest the
results of the election in court
about 85 percent of trumpists believe
trump should go to court
remember the latest is trump doesn't
even think it will work
and when asked whether it will work to
change the election results in hand
trump a victory
trumpists are marginally more realistic
but 60 percent of trump voters
believe what trump is doing will get him
a second term i
really need you to understand that what
we are seeing right now
even though joe biden is moving forward
with appointments
and his transition team a coronavirus
task force
the election is over foreign leaders are
calling joe biden they're already
setting up transition with joe biden
more than half of trump voters expect
that donald trump will be inaugurated to
a second term on january 20th
this is a mind virus donald trump
succeeded not in winning the election
but in using months of rhetoric about
mail-in ballot fraud
and rigged elections to convince most of
his supporters
that it was rigged and that joe biden
didn't really win
but then we really need to get to the
next part which i mentioned earlier this
week
if you watch fox news at night every
anchor is saying this stuff
it was stolen there was fraud illegal
votes illegal ballots
if you only get your news from fox news
and you look at trump's twitter
why would you think anything else their
go-to news sources
are telling them exactly that and 86
percent of trump voters fell for it
86 percent of trump voters is more than
60 million people
60 million people think joe biden didn't
really win
these are doctors your kids teachers
accountants waiters truck drivers you
don't get 60 million from you know
unemployed basement dwelling al-qaeda
if you understand what i'm saying now if
you went and you interviewed some of
these 60 million and you asked them
oh okay you think trump actually won by
the way why did you vote for trump
what first term successes are you most
proud of what issues did you care about
their answers will make no sense and
then you'll have a better understanding
of how 86
fell for this voter fraud uh storyline
but i want to go back to where we
started the week on monday
as ignorant as they may be as
unempathetic as they may be
whatever you want to say about these
people whatever you want to believe
about these people
there's 72 million of them okay biden
barely won
when it came to the margins in the key
three states that ultimately won this
for him
we have to do something about those
trumpists i don't yet know what the
answer is and some people wrote to me
saying
you really should be presenting a
solution well i don't have one yet i'm
being upfront i don't know
this is a real problem it's a mind virus
okay
72 million 60 million believe that trump
actually won i don't yet know the answer
but as soon as i have some ideas i will
come to you
privacy.com is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you five dollars
just for using their free service at
privacy.com
pacman privacy is a service i've been
using for a while now
i love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone
instead of exposing your real credit
card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number
stays completely private and you do it
all with one click you can autofill the
card number
in your web browser on the phone you can
create
12 virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits
freeze them delete them whenever you
want i especially love it for free
trials where you need to give a credit
card number
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
if you're ordering food over the phone
why do i need to give a restaurant my
real card number
i don't have to companies don't have to
know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like and it's completely free
they do have a paid version with
different tiers where you can create
more virtual credit card numbers per
month cash back rewards extra security
features
but go ahead and sign up for the free
service it's a no-brainer companies
can't charge you unexpectedly
you're protected from identity theft it
costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy.com
slash pacman